This video is brought to you by the Ridge wallet.
Hey, wisecrack, Greg here, we're making a shortlist of really funny things.
Chronic despair and unrelenting anxiety probably don't make the cut.
So why are so many comedians these days talking about their mental health and
more importantly, why is it so freaking funny.
That I was gaining weight because my belt stopped fitting around my neck.
The same way that it used to.
Well, indeed over the last few years, and especially since Robin Williams,
tragic death in 2014,
we've seen more and more comments make material out of this struggles with
depression and anxiety and other mental health issues. Pete Davidson,
for example,
has made a running gag of his mental health issues on Saturday night live.
Oh no, no.
No. I was born depressed, but it might make me feel better.
If I was on TV more.
And a part of Nancherla has done the same thing with her anxiety.
Anxiety.
The way I would describe it is like there's an edgy improv group in your
brain.
Gentlemen,
Laney has been cracking jokes about his own mental health struggles and
addiction issues. Since early on in his career.
I actually just quit drinking a couple months ago because, Oh,
I'm not exactly slap happy about it. Myself.
Meanwhile,
comics like bill Hader and Bo Burnham have been open about their experiences
with performance anxiety.
To come to terms with your anxiety on the road.
You know what I mean? In front of thousands of people tonight, it was very,
very abstract.
Comedy might not seem like the most obvious media for exploring mental health
struggles. Given that for most of its history, it's peddled,
largely equipped punchlines and gags purely for laughter sick.
I wish they made fajita cologne because that stuff smells good.
But this recent shift raises some interesting questions for one thing.
How do we get from Bob hubs down? One-liners.
I went to the dentist this morning only had a dollar. What happened?
I had to get bucked teeth.
The comedians dissecting the most intimate details of their mental health
struggles.
If I had had a gun right here,
I would have just brought it up one smooth movement, just like, Oh,
they have French crust pizza dude, dude, dude, dude.
Change a good thing are jokes about anxiety, depression,
and other mental health issues.
Just a new way to get a quick laugh out of a tough situation,
or is there something much deeper going on?
Let's find out in this wise crack additional comedy and mental health. Now,
before we dive into a very serious discussion of some extremely funny people,
I want to give a quick shout out to the people who will help us keep the cameras
rolling our sponsor for this week, the Ridge wallet, the holidays are coming up.
So it's the perfect time to start thinking about what you're going to get your
friends and family, especially the ones that are hard to buy for people,
never think about upgrading their wallet, but they would love it.
If you got them. One of these, the Ridge wallet,
it's sleek and industrial that holds up to 12 cards and has room
for cash.
You can shop all 30 colors and styles to find the perfect match for your loved
ones.
Each wallet is made with durable material and comes with a lifetime warranty.
So your gift will last a lifetime with over 40,005 star reviews.
You can't go wrong. So don't wait for the holidays to fly by visit
ridge.com/wisecrack to view their holiday guide.
And when you read checkout use promo code wise crack,
but 10% off now,
back to the shelf while it's no longer particularly shocking to hear a comedian
joke about depression,
it's worth remembering that the reason focus on mental health and stand up is
pretty unprecedented. For most of this history.
Standup comedy was less about sharing, funny confessional stories,
our observations on stage and more about crafting and delivering clever setups
and punchlines.
My friend George is a radio announcer. And when he walks under a bridge,
you can't hear him talk.
In other words, comics in the early to mid 20th century,
largely focused on laughter for its own sake and then necessarily ground their
material and their real life experiences.
Comics like Bob hope along with Jack Benny and Milton Berle built their sets
around rapid fire jokes.
While their setups often made references to their personal lives.
This was only incidental. The real goal wasn't bearing their soul on stage.
It was landing a surprising punchline.
When I arrived at the airport,
LBJ gave me a one of reception at 21 gun salute and I've got the powder
burns to prove it.
Yeah,
the comedy of this era tended to be escapist more about taking a break from
life's hardships,
then engaging them head on key to that comedic escape is something called
in-congruent that is deliberately creating a gap between what the audience is
expecting to hear and what actually comes out of the comedians.
Mouth philosophers,
as disparate as content Schopenhauer and Kierkegaard have theorized that
congruency is the main ingredient in generating laughter.
We laugh when something disrupts our usual mental patterns and subverts our
expectations.
The classic example is a person who slips on a banana pill while walking the
expectation here is the person can walk. We are very used to seeing this.
We are not used to seeing the person eat instead. Thus,
the incongruity of course has been,
has become so cliche that it's practically an expectation in its own, right?
Which opens up the floor for new banana pill and later gags
in pursuit of in congruent. Some comedians got downright weird with their sets,
creating completely nonsensical material in an attempt to bug the audience's
expectations. Stand-up comedians like Charlie Callas for instance,
made a decades long career out of interrupting his own stories with bizarre
nonsensical noises and facial expressions.
Even more abstractly.
Eighties prop comic Gallagher built entire sets around smashing watermelons with
the hammer and pulling large things out of a giant couch.
[inaudible] Hey,
it was a different time audiences attending these kinds of shows probably
weren't expecting a lot in the way of substance,
but even before Gallagher's watermelon,
smashing comedy was evolving to do more than just dish out jokes.
Beginning of the 1950s and sixties,
a so-called new wave of standup comics like Lenny,
Bruce and George Carlin begin to push the boundaries of what could be said on
stage by incorporating crude humor and social satire into their sets.
Carla, for instance, was famously arrested on obscenity charges,
following a televised routine about the dirty words. One wasn't supposed to say.
Current kids.
In a similar vein comics like Sam Kennison use their stage time to attack social
norms and institutions generally considered sacred.
Well, Michael, if you ever think about getting married,
if you ever think you've met the right woman,
you want to settle down and change your life. Do me a favor, man.
Remember this face.
[Inaudible] more so than earlier comedians.
These comics acted as cultural critics pointing out perceived hypocrisy
throughout history.
This has been a major function of comedy and laughter as scholar Lawrence emits
writes the stand-up comic acts as our comic spokesperson,
a mediator and articulator of our culture and our contemporary
anthropologists. More broadly mince contends that in certain contexts,
the stand-up comic is granted permission to express feelings that will be
difficult to share outside the comedy club.
You are Satan spawn,
filling the world with bile and garbage you are and you are kill yourself.
It's the only way to save your soul.
While performing a skill comic and enacting audiences frustrations with the very
real difficulties of relationships, politics and so on.
And this way they can provide insights into our shared human shortcomings
insights.
That would be entirely unacceptable to share at the company picnic still for the
most part,
new wave comics tended to direct their criticism outward at the broader society
rather than attempting introspection. And that's,
what's so interesting about the present moment,
which we will playfully dove the new new age of comedy more so than ever before.
Comics are turning a Carlin as critical eye inward to comment on themselves and
their community.
Yeah, I think, I think it's hard for black men,
especially to talk about depression because we have so many cool words available
to us to undermine how we really feel. You know.
As a result,
they're able to broach hard truths that for years have been off the table,
even for the boldest of comics.
And trust me when I say this,
nothing is scarier than having to fight your own mind, but.
Is this necessarily a good thing that brings us to one of the central conflicts
in this new new age, namely is laughter a the best medicine, Hey.
Uh, you know, everything you do is going to end in an isolation and entropy.
So what's the point I'm like, you're right. You went again, depression.
Or be an unhealthy coping mechanism.
Depressed. I'm looking for any excuse to not get help.
And the fact that some of my heroes were
messed up was a justification for it.
That clips from laughing matters,
a recent documentary about comedy and mental health in it,
famous actors and comics, including Sarah Silverman,
Wayne Brady and Rainn Wilson speak candidly about the mental health issues
they've dealt with and explore the role that Kali has played in their struggles.
The documentary explores the potential harm of using comedy to escape one's
mental health problems.
I think performing can be a temporary high, but like all temporary highs.
It doesn't last. And you can chase that high night after night after night,
but eventually going,
gonna be club is not open or you're going to have a night off and you're going
to have to deal with what happens in the silence.
Like any other addiction, the high of a great performance contemporarily masks,
the pain of depression, anxiety and so on, but it does.
So without actually helping to solve the underlying issues.
And in some cases it can make them worse than you.
Are thinking about doing comedy as a substitute for therapy
that's doesn't work. I tried, I tried for a long time.
Work to put it bluntly.
The documentary suggest that comedy and laughter have been unproductive and even
destructive for many comedians,
a way to tune out from a life that's falling apart. If that's true,
is it fixable and specifically,
is there a more constructive way to make people laugh?
One that's less about avoiding painful truths and more about facing them to find
out. We can turn to a guy who's not exactly known for its punchy one-liners
philosopher and horse enthusiastic Cratchit nature in general nature
had pretty serious beef with laughter because he viewed it as a potential threat
to our quest for self-actualization as scholar Mark Weitz notes need to thought
the most important human pursuit was embracing our future,
our desires and our power in the face of life's uncertainties for him.
Laughter undercuts this pursuit. Indeed.
According to weeks' interpretation of nature,
laughter off its ability to ground us in the present moment.
By overwhelming us with giggle fits and good feelings can distract from the all
important philosophical question,
constantly striving to improve ourselves in order to build a better future,
to put it another way.
Laughter has a tendency to lift us momentarily out of time by cutting tension
and poking holes in the stories we construct for ourselves. Laughter.
In other words,
it's a loss of the creative tension that the need gen hero needs to construct a
narrative of their life.
A waste of a vital resource while Nisha is hardly an expert in laws and
stand up comedy. As we know it totally didn't exist in 19th century Germany.
He does have a point worth considering as we seen a lot of successful comedy
works by creating an incongruity,
pointing out gaps between expectation and reality. In other words,
undercutting various narratives.
We tell ourselves about the way things ought to go.
Charlie Callas does this by literally cutting himself off.
Bali tells a brief story and Sam Kinison does this by poking holes in the
societal narrative of a happy loving marriage in various ways.
Comedians have historically generated a lot of laughter by disrupting the flow
of personal and societal narratives. Going by nature.
We might consider this a bad thing because while comedians are deconstructing
old and useless narratives, they're not necessarily offering new,
more productive ones to take their place and to bring it back to mental health
and Nietzsche and terms.
Comedy has failed some pretty funny people by offering them a way to temporarily
undercut the narrative of their own lives in the process.
They can numb out and avoid facing their own existential dread and the mental
health issues that might come with it. A lot of existing standup comedy.
In other words, confirms niches,
worst fears about laughter potentially harmful effects on the human spirit.
[Inaudible].
We can't help, but wonder if me too,
might've been more okay with laughter if he spent his time joking with his
friends instead of crying alone in the woods,
which Hey you do you Frederick, nevertheless, this criticism raises a question.
Chicagoans,
try to use laughter to confront their problems rather than to escape from them.
And what might such a new approach be while we have no evidence that any of the
comedians interviewed and laughing matters, dig meta,
they do outline with a more constructive approach to comedy might look like
specifically an approach that transforms their struggles. It's a,
something of a greater value rather than just fodder for that.
We all have these kind of things that happened to us and we can get through
them, you know, we can get through it and transform it and uh, and use it.
Trauma and tragedy. According to these comics are not merely things to laugh at,
even if it feels good,
rather they're the raw materials that comedians can use to craft entirely new
narratives instead of merely shredding apart out dated ones.
You know,
if you're an artist who has a chance to say something that might actually
connect with people or help people, you don't take that chance.
What good aren't you?
This approach to comedy is distinctly Nietzschean. Mark.
Wietz contends that in his later work,
the philosopher made a kind of uneasy peace with laughter by challenging his
readers to will a new kind of laughter one which leads us both amused and
philosophically elevated to put it another way,
need to believe that a constructive self-affirming laughter was possible,
but had yet to be realized in his own time,
he challenged his readers to invent a new form of laughter that would support
her road striving in the face of adversity rather than denigrating such efforts
as being pointless and silly.
And we'd argue that the standup comic who uses their struggles with mental
health as material is helping to make that new laughter a reality.
When a comic crafts, a good story about their struggles,
they are just entertaining.
They're also creating a heroic narrative that shows them facing off against the
real challenges of being human. And in the case of mental health,
that means the difficulty of being completely reliant on a blob of electrified
goop that frequently malfunctions. In other words,
they're responding the neatest challenge by generating laughter that brings
audiences and themselves into direct contact with the past and the future
rather than merely escaping until the hilarity of the present.
We can see this in the work of Sarah Silverman,
like the other comedians interviewed in laughing matters.
She cites her difficult childhood as a sort of origin story for a comedy career.
Then this way she takes a direct look at her past rather than running from it.
A hundred percent of comedians become comedians because somewhere in their
childhood, they needed to be funny in order to survive.
Her refusal to use laughter as a way of covering up as traumas pops up again,
when Silverman describes what happened to the doctor who prescribed her Xanax as
a teenager.
The psychiatrist who originally put me on it hung
himself. I mean,
I can't just skate by that. It's crazy.
This house Silverman laughs and smiles while telling the story,
but refuses to dismiss her psychiatrist suicide as something inconsequential,
she can acknowledge the irony and the situation and even chuckle at it without
denying the traumatic effect that these events had on her younger self.
What's more,
she explains precisely what that effect was drawing a narrative arc from her
past, through her present and into the future.
He's years of torture and shame kind of became my super power.
Silverman is literally framing her comedy career in terms of a superhero's
origin story far from avoiding her problems.
Silverman embraces them as a key part of a creative process without
romanticizing them as the sole source of her funniness depression,
doesn't make a joke out of Silverman. Silverman makes jokes out of depression.
She demonstrates that comedians can transform mental health struggles from a
taboo subject into something worth talking about even celebrating if
only for the duration of a set upon an and Charla for apart applies a similar
technique to the topic of anxiety.
I feel like it's weirder to not have anxiety than to have it.
Cause I feel like if you're not scared, you're not paying attention. You know,
like I feel like if you open a newspaper day skim, maybe three headlines,
you're just like, seems cool is like what? Everything's on fire.
Even the newspaper is on fire. Like what are you so chill about.
Here? And then Charla frames, anxiety, not as a feeling,
but as the only rational response to a society that,
and since we posted happy photos of ourselves on Instagram,
while the world crumbles around us,
that's not to say that everyone needs to get stoked on their own depression or
anxiety, but it's one way to deal.
Comics can also transform trauma into connection with other comics,
our audience members, or insomniacs watching grainy videos on YouTube.
It's one of the reasons that I love being a comedian because if I can find
comedy people anywhere I go in the world and I have,
I know I'm going to hear good stories and I'm going to be sitting around with
people who are also,
if not okay with being at least perhaps more honest about it
than other folks might be.
And once more Nietzschean and transforming trauma into purpose by using their
darkest moments to generate laughter these comics,
aren't just constructing their own heroic narratives.
They're offering us the chance to create ours too. In other words,
if this guy can use human to overcome his mental health struggles,
then maybe there's hope for us and our friends and our cranky coworkers.
The real mission is if your kid is sick or your cousin is
suffering,
or the guy on the other side of the cubicle wall shows up and you never know
which person you're going to get,
how can I make those people understand that that person is not being a
that day and that person's not being melodramatic and it's not because they're
going through a phase. It's because they're.
By making comedy intended to keep us alive and striving for something greater.
These comedians are generating the kind of laughter which needs to might be
proud of a laughter that serves to construct rather than to tear down.
And that's nothing to laugh at. Nah, just kidding. That's pretty good.
Funny. I don't want to be out in the wasteland fat and depressed like that.
There's not going to be any Prozac after that.
But what do you guys think?
Can comedy help us all become better people or should comedians just stick the
smashing watermelons, shout out to Gallagher, let us know in the comments.
And since we're on the subject, if you or anyone, you know,
is going through a hard time, get home,
please reach out and ask for help mostly because you deserve it inherently.
But also because y'all mean a lot to us.
And if you have a need and you can find the link and phone number for the
national suicide prevention lifeline right here in the description below big
thanks to our patrons for all your support,
but be sure to subscribe and ring that bell. And as always,
thanks for watching man. Peace
[inaudible].